[MUSIC PLAYING]
What computer science
paper most influenced you?
This came out when
I was a high school
student, but the universal
gripper, which was basically
just a balloon filled
with coffee grounds,
and it was able to pick up
a wide variety of objects.
And that was a very cool
paper of like, wow, you know,
the stuff that I'm doing in high
school actually can go beyond,
and even very simple techniques
can be very powerful.
I'd say one of the very
first deep learning papers
that I read was DeepMind's
paper on building
autonomous agents that can learn
the game of Atari from scratch.
And this was incredibly
influential to me.
There was a paper called
"Equality of Opportunity
and Supervised
Learning" that came out
the year I started my PhD.
And it was about fairness
in machine learning,
which ended up being a huge
component of my research.
So it's thinking about
how machine learning
impacts people and maybe impacts
different groups differently.
And that has really
changed the way
I think about AI and AI's
responsibility in society.
It's actually a book
by Marc Raibert called
Legged Robots that Balance.
A group of papers
from sociologists
and anthropologists that were
talking about disparities
in health care.
And that was-- those papers
were from a long time
ago, so they weren't really
related to computer science.
But reading them sort of made me
realize how important that work
was to the type of machine
learning applied to health care
that I was working
on at the time.
And so there was a paper
that came out back in 2013
by some people here
and at Disney research.
I think the paper is called
"Computational Design
of Mechanical Characters."
And this was a really exciting
paper to me at the time,
because it was the first one
or one of the first ones that
went from, OK, you make
a digital character
and you want it to
do some sort of task,
and then you want to
fabricate it at the end.
How do you do all of
these three things
in a way that's in
some way optimal?
And this was sort of
coming out at the same time
that I was applying
for PhD programs.
So when I saw that, I was like,
OK, the thing that I'm thinking
I want to do, that's not crazy.
There's people working
in this direction.
It's definitely
going to be possible.
Let's make it happen.
[MUSIC PLAYING]